Jim Foley was an experienced journalist
but his mama was worried when he went
back to Syria he'd been kidnapped once
before while working in the region still
he judged it was worth the risk
then on Thanksgiving Day in 2012 he
failed to make contact with his family
the next morning we received a call from
one of his colleagues telling us that he
had been taken you know it's just like
our worst nightmare really
Islamic extremists had her son what
followed were months of confusion and
frustration their first email was they
wanted over a 100 million euro or all
Muslim prisoners released as I feel our
government's hands were tied and not
able to negotiate if you will with the
captors at all
Dayan became increasingly desperate not
able to get answers from anyone about
what was being done to bring Jim home
that was appalling to me as an American
I just thought oh we could do better
than that's beneath us hold the while
she knew Jim was suffering they were
tortured mentally physically spiritually
in every way they could be Jim was held
nearly two years nearly starved to death
in the first year so just inhuman
conditions then an awful video appeared
on the Internet
it was Jim beheaded as he knelt in the
desert I found out when an hysterical AP
journalist called me sobbing on the
phone that's how I found out so it was
we were incredulous you know we just
weren't shocked truly really um yeah he
was 40 years old one of five siblings
the son of a mom and dad who worked
tirelessly for his release earlier today
I spoke to the Foley's and told them
that we are all heartbroken at their
loss and joined them in honoring Jim
and all that he did Jim's murder came to
symbolize his captors brutality and
hatred of the West but even though Isis
came to prominence on the president's
watch Diane doesn't blame him personally
President Obama was trying to avoid more
confrontation in Middle East but sadly
by not engaging with some of what was
happening it did worsen because there
was a void that we did not fill that
some of these jihadist groups were very
quick to fill still she has little time
for Trump's promise to bomb the hell out
of Isis instead focused on her son's
legacy and preventing other similar
tragedies there's nothing worse for a
parent than to lose a child - there
really isn't but Jim's strength and own
courage at the end of his life
challenged me as a mom in a big way that
if he could have the courage to stand up
to these folks who were doing this to
him and to do his best to protect those
he was with I too should do my best to
make things better Jim would have wanted
that Jim always wanted to make things
better for someone else